it came as a big shock for me
that what i was starting to capture from
the beginning was
global movement
the eyes of all future generations are
upon you
and if you choose to fail us i say we
will never
forgive you
[Music]
i've been interested in in the topic of
climate change when it comes to
storytelling for a long time
in this specific case we got a tip and
this tip
was a friend that knew greta's family a
little bit and i googled her name
you know there was nothing about her
except one
kind of debate article that she had
written
and in that article she also said that
she had asperger's syndrome
i didn't know that much about it but it
felt like it was in some way
connected to how does she as a young
person
see this huge scary issue of climate
change as someone who's going to be
affected by that in the future
so i brought the camera and i took a
friend with me who's a sound designer
and we went down to riksdogen which is
the government
building outside the parliament here in
sweden to start filming her and see who
she was
she had seated herself and i don't know
how long she had been there maybe a few
hours or something
we were able to capture her from the
beginning
i had no idea what she wanted or where
she was going with the activism
so i went in with a very open mind
[Music]
and it was so interesting diving into
that world reverse
i think greta was very exposed to this
kind of quick media
a lot in the beginning
but i was not that media
i always wanted this movie to be a movie
kind of told from the inside
in the sense that i wanted it to be kind
of greta
more kind of trying to show us her world
that we would understand
this story from her point of view and i
think that was something that made her
relax
around me to access her life
[Music]
time went by and and bit by bit
we formed this closer bomb
and i just looked at her through the
viewfinder every day
and say okay who is greta sandberg today
i've actually filmed almost everything
myself
it gives me the opportunity to almost
hear the breath and the heartbeat of the
person that i'm following
and by doing that i get kind of
emotionally
attached to that person and to the story
where
in this movie i've laughed so many times
so that we haven't been able
to use the footage because the camera
has been shaking
[Music]
and i've been crying through the
viewfinder as well
[Music]
for me feeling all those emotions why
being in situations with greta
and bringing the viewer you know to
those moments
was so important to create a human being
out of her i simply
can't talk she's not just this angry
screaming girl in the u.n but also
this nerdy teenager that has different
dimensions
i remember when greta told me one day
that she had posted on
her social media accounts for a lift to
sail over the atlantic ocean
and i just felt like oh my god no
i was [ __ ] scared
these boats are nothing like these big
yachts that you've seen in the hamptons
it's basically a huge sail attached to
this super light hull it kind of leaps
in the wind really muscular
jumps forward but what that means is
that it crashes against the waves in a
sense it's a giant drum
so i talked to the captain and i talked
a little bit more to greta
and then understood that this was going
to be a very special journey
we had like a big production meeting and
i talked to this guy who was a
specialist at filming
on on these boats and he was like you
need to carry
like three cameras and i was like why
because
everything will break so we brought
all the gear that he said that we should
have
after just a few days everything broke
the opening shot that everyone thinks is
so dramatic and so cinematic
it was actually one of the more cold
days
after a few days on the boat we and our
minds and our bodies kind of adapted
to this crazy jungle of
carbon fiber and ropes and
sounds and then here the wind is from
behind and light
so here's the high pressure this will be
quite
funky and after that the wind is strong
from behind it's also not
it only starts to blow stronger
five in the morning tomorrow morning
it will be a bit challenging but uh
only one thing in a sense that i know
will be true
and that is my curiosity it guided me
through this process
of making this movie
i wanted to be able to capture the
moments exactly when they played out
her expressions draws the camera close
to her
just like the camera wanted that
and it became a very intimate style
[Music]
this was really pushing my boundaries of
cinematography
we are in the middle of the atlantic
ocean
the water is kind of spraying around
this boat
we're moving in 20 knots or something
but i have this responsibility towards
her
and towards the world to capture this
journey
and also i have a responsibility towards
myself i need to
survive this trip because if you get
seasick it can actually be dangerous on
these boats
this is much more an emotional film than
this an informational feel
they brought the new telephone
[Music]
what we want and water
with a teether
[Music]
it of course becomes a big kind of
burden on greta's shoulders that she
maybe didn't have thought about when she
started this journey
this weekend i'm sorry
[Music]
you ever need to bear where you
[Music]
dignity
[Music]
you could almost do like a documentary
just about what happened on that boat
[Applause]
we tend to forget now this is really
like a small
grass root activism that started in
sweden from nothing
it grew and grew and grew
she was of course an international kind
of celebrity and maybe
the most famous climate activist that
we've ever seen on the planet
film really kind of showcases how
quickly
this year went for greta
when i understood that this was
something happening in in hyperlapse
speed
it was definitely when greta met the
pope and i was like
jesus like eight months ago
she was sitting on this cold
cobblestone street in stockholm and now
i'm desperately trying
to get kind of the sharpness right onto
pope francisco's eye
forming the narrative of the film one
thing that struck me very much
filming was how interesting it became
kind of juxtaposing
kind of regular small situations with
kind of these
huge kind of speeches and this these
moments that greta was you know
from kind of you know meeting the pope
it could swing over just in like 10
minutes to
something which which was just this
small weird and funny moment that
anyone could kind of recognize
[Applause]
after watching i am greta of course you
will
understand the effects of climate change
and you will understand how important it
is that we
create a world where we can have climate
justice but there's also this kind of
sub
thread of the film which is about
greta's diagnosis
and about seeing the world differently
to be able to see injustices in all
different
parts of society and i think in that
sense
greta is such an important person
the world is waking up and change
is coming whether you like it or not
[Music]
you